[Musique]
ou tu aimais mais vous êtes là bon je
vois la réunion dongeois le monde
comment il est si zot lé bien mal et
mieux bienvenue dans les pas sorti de
l'auberge
il fait beau il fait chaud on est dans
les eaux de l'étang salé on va visiter
une ville à my aux huiles essentielles
ont petit spa une petite salle de sport
fin bref quoi tout ce qu'il faut pour
être bien est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
commencer cette visite magnifique nylon
nous non devenez alors venez avec moi
non viens viens petit bonhomme
[Musique]
bonjour laurent gerra l'ex un plaisir de
te rencontrer et merci de venir la villa
romeo si beaucoup merci beaucoup
déjà franchement c'est très joli moi je
vois trois fleurs trois fleurs et je
suis déjà mort odieux de l'endroit dis
moi où est ce qu'on est si on à étang
salé donc un petit peu dans les eaux on
à 230 mètres d'altitude ce qui nous
permet d'être pas dans la chaleur mais
par contre d'avoir une jolie vue sur la
mer gelée vue sur la mer et puis moi
j'ai entendu parler de beaucoup de
petites choses hyper sympathique que tu
proposes à tes clients est déjà là je
vois des petits flacons qui sont là ça
m'interpelle
bah écoute un moment donné ça peut
interpeller quoi une chambre d'hôte
c'est une tranche de vie donc les
avantages que l'on a c'est que on
rencontre des autres de partout de la
réunion de métropole de l'étranger et du
coup c'est super parce que on partage un
temps avec eux parfois c'est court
parfois c'est long mon al'avantage de
partager une tranche de leur vie sur la
partie à romont travaille sur deux
directions la partie olfactives et la
partie gustatives aux actifs parce que
toutes nos chambres ont un nom lié à une
huile essentielle de l'océan indien
vétiver camphre géraniums cryptomérias
ylang ylang et c'est pour ça qu'elles
sont là il se trouve que dans nos
chambres on a des diffuseur de senteurs
et donc on fait sentir les huiles à nos
hôtes ce qui leur permet de passer un
bon moment tranquille dans leur chambre
de cocooning voilà quoi c'est une espèce
d'apprentissage c'est vrai que tu
arrives tu voulais pas trop la réunion
mais qu'est ce que tu as envie de faire
garder un petit peu et des bas ça passe
par les eaux de gaza passe par les goûts
6 10 mois ses yeux essentiel je vois que
c'est écrit saint joseph et si
évidemment on va au marché de saint
pierre et puis on trouve toutes nos
villes
tu sais ce que tu vas faire moi j'ai
franchement dit que tu me montres la
suite on y va on y va
ok
ses vertus timide aujourd'hui il est
timide je sais pas ce qui se passe
je voudrais quand même qu'ici on a vu
sur le volcan donc au niveau de notre
établissement
le matin bien sûr parce que souvent ils
un peu fini aux stores là on a la chance
de voir le volcan il ya le petit piton
mon verre là bas exact ma maison est
juste derrière
c'est exact les voisins finalement c'est
ça la réunion dans ses parfums des
marques
[Musique]
magnifique donc c'est la vue sur la
forêt de l'etang-salé qui est la plus
grande forêt débat si on compare les
eaux le parc national
et puis la forêt débat dont 230 mètres
d'altitude ce qui nous permet d'avoir
une jolie vue sur la mer et donc ici on
fait les petits déjeuners et en fait les
tables d'hôtes airgas quant à préparer
j'espère ça te conviendra qu'on a parlé
lui ses paroles et ses mots tout est
fait maison
le pain est fait maison les
viennoiseries sont faites maison les
yaourts les jus de fruits tout est fait
maison et confitures ou kiki qui aux
fourneaux pour justement le pain fait
maison les biscuits faits maison c'est
philippe qui est le cuisinier
moi je suis plutôt celles qui
accueillent qui s'occupe des chambres
mais le vrai cuisinier c'est le philippe
donc tout à l'heure en valeur voir parce
que je crois qu'il te prépare quelque
chose pour ce midi mais on est gâté on
est vraiment gâté on va voir la suite
allez je te présente le spar alors ça
fait partie des choses que les gens
aiment bien parce qu'on est vraiment sur
un concept de co poule
[Musique]
fanny chemin oui oui un mec sérieux non
elle rigole
non me suis dispensé heureusement
j'avais c'est vrai et
[Musique]
alors maintenant je ramène la biotech
zola direct
[Musique]
si je m'arrête un dessin pour te parler
de ma vie
juste comme ça tranquillement
bars et de raconter les souvenirs
bien gravé dans ma mémoire est-ce que ça
m'intéresserait de voir ce qu'on prépare
pour le repas et ça sert à rien même de
poser la question tellement je vais
devient oui ça c'est comme bonnes
aptitudes de l'appétit mais mais c'est
bon je pète il est la fille de philippe
qui est aux commandes
moi je m'occupe du reste mais lui l'a de
cuisine c'est son domaine
allez quoi là on va le voir allez on y
va
philippe bonjour lettre alors comment il
est très bien ça va très bien je suis en
train de confectionner et nos moules ça
au chocolat au combat va donc le combat
va c'est pour que comme je le dis
bourbeau nous aimons plein voilà je
bourbeau nice to me plaît même en fait
c'est ça c'est que florence et de mehdi
tiens tu viens dans la cuisine
tu vas rencontrer philippe est en fait
philippe il y est il est à la cuisine
vraiment une très jolie petite place il
s'agissait vous faire des pros plagne le
combat va bien sûr qui vient du jardin
qui vient de la banque est juste à côté
marin alors cet art il a 25 ans
honnêtement et c'est un arbre dont je
prends beaucoup de soin je suis en
accueil à peu près par an 150 à 200 mais
c'est vraiment super et les belges
seront profitant pour faire l'étude in
avec l'enfer du rhône j'ai inventé en vo
c'est bourbeau disais-je président
bozizé masque à réaliser voilà ce qu'a
réalisé pour venise est tout à fait ce
que j'appelle pour baliser c'est que je
profite des épices qui les assure lise
c'est vraiment extraordinaire quand on
est venu ici avec florence ya vingt ans
je m'amusais à frotter toutes les
franges de fleurs il s'en tire mes
doigts et à chaque fois il me suis dit
mais c'est pas possible
il a d euros partout j'essaie de
profiter de tout on a plein de deux des
pis ici on a le 4 épices en haut on a le
basilic on à la citronnelle à la ja pas
là
on a vraiment beaucoup de choses
beaucoup je vous en ai vraiment gâté
heureux ici avec tout ce qui pousse à la
règle c'est ce que j'ai envie de dire
goutta nous goutailloux tu prends tout
ça dans les marchés j'ai ma vendeuse à
qui fait un coucou un gars qui est en
bas coût qui est en bas donc de l'étang
salé ce sont des fruits qui sont bio
mais la politique ce sont des fruits qui
sont vraiment très très bon très bien là
je vais me fournit à tous les matins
pratiquement et sinon je me fournis
beaucoup marcher je me fournis donc si
dégoût mon groupe en deux pêcheurs qui
rend bas à qui je fais coucou aussi donc
voila quoi vraiment des producteurs
locaux et c'est vraiment moi ça me fait
un malin plaisir de manger comme ça je
vous prépare une petite assiette de
présents je fais ça avec une magnifique
car en bleu
[Musique]
se trouve que on est pas très nombreux
en 4 étoiles ou quatre clés ou 4 épis
tout ce qu'on veut on n'est pas très
nombreux à faire table d'hôte et nous
nos spécialités c'est de faire
intégralement du fait maison comme on
avait dit avant et donc du coup il faut
faire quelque chose qui peuvent un peu
aussi surprendre les réunionnais malgré
le fait qu'on soit la réunion donc en
particulier tu verras sur ta gauche ont
fait des chiffres de songe au milieu tu
auras une crème de poivron avec une
petite muslim de citron et puis sur ta
droite tu auras des canards ont alors dû
camarons la terrier qui bourgogne ce qui
est très bien c'est qu'on retrouve
justement nos produits et sa basse et
valorisant aussi pour aller mais je t'en
remercie
[Musique]
voilà et voilà c'est l'interview de fin
cette interview que je redoute tant
parce qu'à la fin j'ai dit tout le monde
au revoir et j'ai subi
je suis désolé de partir mais bon on n'y
est pas encore comment vous en êtes
arrivé à accueillir des gens en fait de
la cuisine faut des gens à faire des
champs bien qu elle ait des gens comme
ça dans un endroit magnifique d'ailleurs
fait on était parisien et puis on a vu
une vie très confortable très agréable
moi je travaillais dans l'international
philippe travaillé à la sncf
et puis il se trouve que si on a
traversé la réunion mais ya vingt ans
puis à 10 ans et donc du coup on a eu un
coup de coeur sur la partie nature non
seulement la montagne mais aussi la mer
c'est aussi pour ça qu'on n'est pas très
loin de la mer c'est qu'on aime
là où on a eu envie d'un changement un
peu radical certes on se retrouve à la
campagne mais avec une richesse de
rencontres qui nous convient bien au
monde les avait on pique tout on y va et
c'est ça globalement moi je
lire différents clients qui initie si
beaucoup plus intéressant de vendre du
bonheur que de vente des contraintes
exact je sais qu'il ya des sentiers
emballé sentir en eau
dites moi un petit peu ce que le client
peut faire une fois qu'il vient ici dans
sa journée
la première chose que nous sommes en
avance et la forêt on a une forêt qui
est la plus grande forêt débat où on
peut courir faire du vélo faire du
cheval
on peut tout à fait simplement marcher
il ya énormément de sentiers je crois
que j ai pu me disaient qu'ils allaient
au 10 km de pistes donc 70 km de pistes
de penser qu'un âne très jolie forêt qui
est pas très loin qui s'appelle était
valable
on a les mac avec une vue magnifique
sorcier la hausse est de nouveau sur la
journée on gravite sur volcans sur
cilaos on veut très facilement faire des
choses de en partant de chez nous ce qui
est magnifique c'est ça c'est qu'on peut
on peut avoir la la fraîcheur des hauts
avec les sentiers on peut avoir la
chaleur tropicale
on peut avoir donc ce côté plage
dhabhawi en bas avec l'étang salé plus
les sentiers il ya vraiment de quoi il
ya vraiment de quoi bouger
lorsqu'on vient sur l'étang salé on a
fait le tour
je pense qu'on a fait le tour ben moi je
demande allait bien alex je vais m'en
aller
à bientôt j'ai envie de rester à très
bientôt
on espère je veux revenir juste après a
offert un petit tour dans une heure pas
de grand plaisir il ya une semaine mais
ce sera toujours avec plaisir à la
greenshoe même juste après la balle tout
de suite
[Musique]
et où les enfants toutes les bonnes
choses ont une fin
on n'est pas sorti de l'auberge c'est
terminé pour aujourd'hui mais ne pleurez
pas je vous promets je vais revenir
alors le mans j'étais bien bon mais
espère en effet un petit show l'étang
salé parce que franchement là beaucoup
de choses à faire et puis à on n'est
vraiment pas sorti de l'auberge
non vraiment pas c'est mon avis parce
que quand on sort de l'auberge à un
moment donné tu sors comme sam et ont
voté plein
[Musique]